[MUSIC]
I was working at a nonprofit called
Generation when I met Jasmine.
Jasmine was only 24 years old, but
she had already been through a lot and
life kept throwing her
curveball after curveball.
She had held a few jobs off and
on, but most were part-time and
it was hard to manage her work schedule
with caring for her one year-old daughter.
She was living with her
daughter's father for a while, so
that provided some stability.
But unfortunately he developed
an alcohol abuse problem, and
she began to fear for
own safety and her daughter's.
Jasmine found a community in Atlanta
that provides a safe haven for
women who have escaped abusive situations.
With the solid footing of housing and
safety, she began to look for
full time work, determined to create
a better world for her daughter.
One that held the promise of
opportunity that she never had.
Jasmine's determination was admirable.
She applied to multiple jobs every day,
but
received interviews from
very few employers.
The interviews she had,
they weren't going so well either.
She knew someone had to be hiring, but
despite her best efforts,
no one wanted to hire Jasmine.
This story is not uncommon.
What I found from my work at Generation
is that while the details may change,
similar circumstances are experienced
by many unemployed young people.
Now, when I say unemployed young people,
I mean those aged 18 to 29 who
are not in school and
are actively searching for work.
The International Labor Organization
estimates that around the world,
75 million young people are unemployed.
Three times as many are underemployed.
This represents not just a source
of individual despair, but
also a source of social unrest, as well
as a gigantic pool of untapped talent.
Paradoxically, this is
a two-sided problem.
According to a global report
by McKinsey & Company,
40% of employers say that a skill shortage
is driving entry-level vacancies.
Meaning, employers cannot find the skills
that they need in the labor pool.
This problem has persisted for years, but
it is only now beginning to be addressed.
The solution I proposed,
modeled on this issue,
is to create partnerships between
the nonprofit and for-profit worlds
that from the outset align outcomes and
enable stronger collaboration.
I believe this proposition is valuable
in many sectors, but for the purpose of
illustration, let's consider this issue
of unemployment among young people.
There are three critical aspects of
the education-to-employment journey.
First, enrollment.
Are enough young people being trained for
the job market?
Two, building skills.
Is training giving young
people the right skills?
And three, finding a job.
Can young job seekers find open positions?
So why does it not work for
nonprofits to solve this issue alone?
A nonprofit that focuses on skills
training has many priorities.
With limited time and
resources, attending to this
entire education-to-employment
journey is nearly impossible.
And there are outstanding questions
on all three of these aspects.
First, enrollment.
The nonprofit sector is highly fragmented,
and
with a donation-based business model,
nonprofits cannot operate at the scale
needed to serve all of the young people
who would benefit from their services.
Two, building skills.
Without employer involvement,
there is no mechanism to ensure that
the curriculum and delivery is done in
a way that prepares young people to
be successful on the job,
not just in the classroom.
And third, finding a job.
Without commitments from, or at least
connections with employers, nonprofits
may not be helping young people with the
critical piece of actually landing a job.
So now, let's shift gears and
consider the other side of the coin,
the for-profit world.
In this case, that means employers.
Why do employers not
solve this issue alone?
Why don't they just hire young people,
and then train them?
The problem is, it's expensive.
The employer would have to invest
in developing the right type of
skills training.
And then when they hire employees, these
employees spend a long time being trained.
And during that time, they're not
producing output for the company.
Some large employers do have the capacity
to develop training programs.
But the reality is, most unemployed young
people aren't going to be working for
these resource-rich large companies.
Additionally, many unemployed young people
come from difficult life situations,
similar to Jasmine.
They need social support
structures in place
to help them succeed in their training and
in their transition to the workplace.
And this is why nonprofits
are also needed as part of
the equation to address the social
issues of unemployment,
not just the talent development piece
in which employers are invested.
In 2015, Generation, where I worked, was
launched to bring together the nonprofit
and for-profit worlds to solve this issue
of unemployment among young people.
When Jasmine went through
the Generation Program,
she benefited tremendously
from this model.
As a nonprofit,
Generation was able to provide social
support services such as a mentor, and
a stipend to help her recover,
her transportation, and food cost.
The program's emphasis on employer
involvement was also key to
Jasmine's success.
For instance, Generation had worked
directly with employers from
the beginning to identify the key
skills and mindsets they needed.
And this was the foundation for
Jasmine's training.
Generation has focused on proving
the positive return on investment of
the program.
As this return on investment is proven,
Generation's funding sources have become
diverse, and include governments,
foundations, and employers themselves.
All stakeholders benefit
from this collaboration.
Governments reduce their
unemployment rate,
foundations provide economic mobility for
young people, and
employers have a pipeline of talent with
reduced turnover and higher productivity.
This collaboration is essential to reach
the scale needed to truly move the needle
on unemployment among young people.
When Jasmine graduated from
the Generation Program,
she received the job of her dreams.
She called me and
said something to the effect of,
I feel like my life has changed already.
I want my daughter,
when she's grown, to look back and
be proud of the life we made.
I think that's possible now.
The program worked for Jasmine.
The program has worked for
over 25,000 young people in
99 cities across 9 countries,
and it's expanding rapidly.
I had the opportunity to help launch
the Generation Hong Kong program
in Spring 2018,
right before coming to Stanford.
Here's a photo of their
first graduation ceremony.
The program is impactful and scalable,
and this would not be possible
without the collaboration among
sectors in each Generation location.
Today I've told you a story about
unemployment among young adults,
because it's an issue that
matters deeply to me.
But I'm also excited to be
sharing my story with you
because I want to extend an invitation.
I invite you to think about an issue
that matters deeply to you.
It could be malnutrition, financial
insecurity, access to healthcare,
or any other issue that moves you.
What would be possible if nonprofit and
for-profit organizations worked
hand in hand every step of the way,
like they've done for Jasmine and
like they've done for
thousands of other unemployed
young people around the world?
I challenge you to extend this model
to the issue that matters to you,
because there are so
many more people in our communities and
around the world that we can help.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]